[Music]
hey you guys here we are back again with
yet another book review i think this is
one that i talked about way back on my
tbr show it was kind of in my pile of
books that i had read a long time ago
but i remembered really liking and
wanted to revisit them for this show
because i had like a whole bunch of
paperbacks that i bought back in the day
when i was reading and buying like a
really lot of horror fiction and i'm
really glad i got to revisit this one i
kind of i remembered the premise and
that was about it uh but i actually
really ended up uh liking it and
enjoying it very much also the second
time this is dark fall
by stephen laws now uh interestingly
there's also a novel uh by dean koontz
which is also called dark fall i'm not
sure if it came out around the same time
as this but like i haven't read that one
so i don't know if it's any good or not
but they the two of them have nothing to
do with each other i'm not i have to say
i've only read like a couple of dean
koontz novels i'm not a massive fan but
you know what i mean it's like i haven't
really read enough of his stuff to you
know have too much an opinion about it
i'm just saying i've read a couple of
this and i didn't really like them all
that much however steven laws is uh
actually quite rad he's a british writer
he's from newcastle upon tyne i believe
and that is where this book is set i've
actually when i was thinking about it i
was looking at his um
you know all of his novel output and
stuff and i'm like actually i think i've
read several of his i read one called
the worm which is w-y-r-m which is kind
of like almost like a folk horror type
thing which was very good um and i read
one and i might have it in my closet or
in the attic or something like that
called fear me which i think was like a
stalker vampire type of story and that
was also very good steven laws kind of
writes he occupies like the same kind of
space generally as somebody like richard
layman or bentley little or something
like that kind of extreme horror not as
extreme maybe as you know like jack
ketchum or something like that but there
is this book in particular has a lot of
kind of weird like it's almost i almost
want to say sci-fi but not quite
but it does have a lot of like body
horror at the end of it almost kind of
goes like in a clive barkery sort of
direction
so if you don't want to know anything
about this book other than they do give
a couple things away on the back but if
you don't want to know anything about it
before going in this is actually a
really good book it's very fast-paced uh
it's a page turner you're just gonna and
it's kind of like it's good because it's
sort of
mostly centered around one location and
it's just kind of like almost kind of
like a survival
horror to like people just trying to
like get out of this place or like get
away from a bunch of monsters and stuff
so if that sounds like something that is
up your alley like i said there's some
pretty gross body horror and you know
transmogrification type [ __ ] going on
later on if that sounds like something
you'd like then go read it i'm not
necessarily going to spoil the end or
anything but
again it's like really hard to talk
about
books movies anything
without saying what happens in the plot
uh so you know so if you don't want to
know anything about it then
go read it and then come back i kind of
feel like okay so the copyright on this
says
1992
but this particular edition which i
believe is from leisure books who like i
said we're doing a lot of paperback
horror in the early 2000s this actually
came out in 2003 this version of it here
it seems like it's kind of i don't know
it seems like it's kind of difficult to
get some of his stuff because some of
it's gone out of print i'm not sure if
he's still writing he's he's written
like a bunch of novels and a bunch of
short stories and i believe he also
teaches or used to teach creative
writing that type of stuff so
i'm not really sure if he's uh still
around but like i said
it's just like a really good it's like
an action-packed
thrill ride type of book you know what i
mean it's just kind of like all almost
all in one location and it's just people
like trying to get away from us and like
you know bad [ __ ] keeps happening to
them and they're trying to like get out
of the situation so we'll get into that
what the premise of this and i actually
kind of love the premise of this the
reason why i say it's kind of like
sci-fi
it's but it's one of those kind of
sci-fi uh
concepts that's just kind of like don't
think about it too hard you know what
i'm saying it's that type of thing but
uh you know it's because it almost kind
of kind of has like a little bit of like
an alchemical type of uh you know sort
of
veneer to it which actually i quite like
so
this story starts out with a guy who's
like um the caretaker you know janitor
type you know custodian type dude
and he is in the basement of this big
huge uh office building i think it's
called fernley house uh office park or
whatever in newcastle upon tyne it's
christmas eve
and he's down in the basement uh you
know drinking
as you do
on christmas eve and uh upstairs uh
there are a bunch of like office parties
going on like all these different
companies that are in this office block
have you know closed the doors for the
day but you know now it's presumably
like 6 or 7 pm
and you know back in the back in the day
back in the 90s i don't know how common
this is nowadays
but
they kind of just like decorate the
office bring in some alcohol put you
know somebody put some flashy lights and
disco music on or whatever and everybody
starts dancing getting drunk making out
with co-workers that they will regret
the next day all that type of stuff so
all of that is presumably going on
upstairs uh the custodian downstairs is
really kind of cranky about it because
like i said he had to work and he just
thinks they're a bunch of tweed gits or
whatever they would say like in the uk
like up their party and whatnot but then
something interesting happens like or
something actually quite horrifying
happens he hears these really really
loud banging sounds and they seem to be
coming from the boilers
now he's never heard anything quite this
horrific before so he jumps to the
reasonable conclusion that the boilers
are you know over
overheating or whatever or that they're
going to explode so he's basically like
well [ __ ] i have to go upstairs and get
all these people out of here now
meanwhile there's also like a really bad
storm going on outside uh and one that
seems a little like way way worse than
usual it's just there's snow and
lightning and thunder and everything
like that way worse than usual and also
there's like something seemingly very
mysterious about it
so he tries to go upstairs to
warn all of these people um you know hey
the boiler might explode we really need
to get everybody out of the building he
attempts to contact various authorities
and can't really get hold of anybody
mostly because it's christmas eve
everyone's just kind of you know [ __ ]
around or they want to go home or
whatever and also because
the storm outside has caused a lot of
kind of electrical disturbances so he
can't really seem to raise anyone like
on the phone or the radio or anything
like that so he goes upstairs to try to
get people out of the building
and it is then that he notices even
though it looks like everybody was still
like partying uh as in music and lights
are still going um you know people's
drinks and food is just like still
sitting there everyone in the building
has mysteriously disappeared
and he can't figure out where the [ __ ]
they went
now at first he's kind of like well
maybe they all just left and like they
just left in this big mess like this but
he's like that can't be it's like why
you know he's like i didn't hear anybody
leave i didn't see anybody leave it's
like there was like i think there was
something like 60 people in there like
having parties in various offices and
he's like you know people don't just
disappear now he thinks it's weird but
he doesn't really think anything too
badly about it at this point however
when he goes into one office and he kind
of goes behind this like screen or
whatever he finds what is very obviously
a severed human hand which has been
severed very cleanly at the wrist
at which point he flips the [ __ ] out as
he would and calls the police
now because he warned the police he's
like look i came up here because i
thought the boiler was gonna explode um
obviously but he's like look i found
this hand up in here everybody's gone i
don't know where they went all their
cars are still in the in the parking lot
he's like so it's just super weird all
these people just like went missing so
the cops get there and uh as soon as
they send a team in there to determine
that the boilers are in fact fine and
they're not going to explode so they
can't figure out what that noise was
that started off this whole adventure
they don't really believe him uh not
only because this is a crazy story hey
60 people just vanished into thin air
and oh also there's like a severed man's
hand laying on the floor for no reason
um but also because he had been drinking
prior so and he's not you know he's kind
of drunk and he's kind of like freaked
out uh not only because of the noise
because of everybody like being gone so
he's not being like super articulate so
they basically think okay well this
guy's just a nut case or it's a prank or
something like that so
they don't really do all that much about
it however as the night goes on other
people start getting involved and it
seems that maybe the storm that's going
on outside is kind of a particular
i want to call it like a scientific or
an atmospheric or something like that
anomaly
and it turns out too that there's this
uh one of those secret government
agencies
that kind of knows what this is because
it's like happened before
so basically what's going on and like i
said from this point because all that
stuff like about him you know
about the guy finding the hand and
everybody being missing all that stuff
has kind of like gone into on the back
of the book but from this point forward
um this is kind of like spoilery like
just
you know it just about like plot points
in general so as i said this is kind of
like last chance if you want to read it
and not know anything about gomez
because i think this book
is really good if you don't know
where it's going you know what i'm
saying because
it's kind of one of those things where
it's almost like the first half of it
it's fairly long it's like 400 something
pages but the first half of it is kind
of like a mystery because you're not
really sure like where the [ __ ] did all
these people go
um you know where how did this hand get
here you know and then like even crazier
[ __ ] starts happening later as in
this one woman turns up like on the
streets of london you know several you
know many miles away from newcastle she
turns up in the street she doesn't
really remember where she is she's all
disheveled and she basically starts
attacking people and she kind of goes
out into the road and a car
swerves to avoid her and smashes into
like a pole or something like that and
then she jumps into the car and starts
eating the dude's face so you know
there's there's kind of that kind of
[ __ ] going on
also elsewhere there's this other couple
and they're kind of like cooking a
turkey in their kitchen or whatever and
they hear this horrendous crash like in
their backyard and they go out there and
see that their greenhouse their glass
greenhouse has been broken at first they
just think oh it's some you know
neighborhood kids or whatever being
dicks and throwing rocks at it but then
they find out that no a body has crashed
through the top of this greenhouse and
they can't figure out where the body
came from and the body doesn't have a
hand and it wasn't severed so you're led
to believe that this is the owner of the
hand that they found back at the office
block um which they quickly determined
through
triangulating you know various ids and
stuff like that but this guy they're
like well nobody threw the body into the
greenhouse and there's nothing above
your house so obviously it fell from a
great height he maybe he fell out of an
airplane that's pretty much all that
they know about it so as the story goes
on and kind of our main protagonist
because like i said at first you're it's
kind of like the dude that's the
custodian because he's like the first
experiencer of it and then like some
other cops come in but then they get
this one detective in there named jack
cardiff who was kind of like your main
protagonist um he's still on the force
but at the beginning of the book he's
actually really suicidal i believe it
was like a year prior uh he had been
involved in a hit and run like a um
like a driver
had crashed up onto the pavement or the
sidewalk as we'd say in the u.s and hit
him and also hit his wife and his son uh
his wife and his son were killed uh but
he survived and he's haunted by this
vision of the person who was driving the
car who he is certain had no face
so
he's kind of like thinking about ending
it all when he gets this crazy call
now the more that they look into this
weird ass because they all kind of go
into the building and they're looking
around and then they send a search party
up to look for the 60 odd people that
have disappeared and that search party
of seven people also disappears and then
they start hearing
voices that seem to be coming out of the
walls and seem to be like yelling for
them to help them like they don't know
where they are and all this other kind
of stuff
so at this point um you know and the
weird [ __ ] that's going on with them
finding the hand and then matching the
hand up with this body that crashed
through a greenhouse somehow like many
miles away so they're like okay well
this is some weird [ __ ] and then he
remembers uh that a year or two before
he had picked up like this petty
criminal named jimmy devlin who had been
in the middle of like robbing a jewelry
store or something like that and he had
told the police a story that the two his
two compatriots his two accomplices had
basically been sucked into a wall while
he was watching and he got the [ __ ] out
of there now obviously he got done for
the crime it's like nobody believed him
uh because it's a crazy ass story but
because jack carter remembered that
weird ass story then remember the weird
ass story that he had told he goes to a
pub and gets and picks up jimmy devlin
and you know brings him in on the like
as a consultant like on the
investigation because he has apparently
seen something like this before uh and
as that goes on as that investigation
goes on also there's this government
agency like i said that comes in led by
a dude named romer who is very
sketchy not sketchy but he's just like
you sinister i guess is a better word
and he seems to know a lot more about
what's going on than anyone else and
doesn't really isn't real free with that
information but basically what you come
to is that
these storms that happen are some kind
of i mean like i said it's not like hard
science or anything like that but it's
some kind of electrical alchemical sort
of reaction and every now and then
there'll be this big huge storm it's
very localized and what it will
essentially do is it sort of takes away
the boundary between living tissue and
non-living tissue so what ended up
happening with all those people at the
party is that because this storm which
this government agency has codenamed a
darkfall it's centered around this one
office building in this one particular
place
and
made it so that the people that were in
the building became essentially absorbed
into the building so they're still in
there
but their bodies have been
integrated with
the non-living material of the building
you know concrete steel whatever
and uh so they're still alive somehow
but there's also a thing called a
returner they said ever which is you
know the guy that fell through the
greenhouse the woman that came out on
the street and started eating people
when the people return by and large
they're not really normal anymore they
do seem to have they retain some of
their human attributes and some of their
memories and things but because they've
been integrated in various ways with the
inorganic material that they were
absorbed into
a lot of them come out sort of monstrous
either they you know they'll be like
you know have crazy like the one common
thing is uh you know somebody will get
sucked into the wall and if you get
sucked back out like they'll start
liquid concrete will like start coming
out of their mouth and stuff like that
you know but they're still like i said
alive and they're still kind of strong
so basically you have you know people
get picked off one by one people get
sucked into the walls there's various
rules about what what will happen
because the even though the storm's
going all the time it doesn't always you
know it has to be like a certain there
has to be like a certain something going
on in the darkfall storm
for this uh porousness to come so people
start getting absorbed into the building
essentially
so what you have
other than you know the first little bit
of the book which like i said it kind of
goes into a little bit of character
development a little stuff that's you
know happening outside like with the
woman that ends up in london and like
with the guy that crashes through the
greenhouse and then like introduce
introducing us to jack cardiff and jimmy
devlin and people like that
other than that uh pretty much the
entire story takes place inside this
office block as all of these cops
detectives and other people that are
still in there are trying to
figure out what's going on and once they
figure out what's going on how they can
you know stop it or how they can get the
[ __ ] out of the building without you
know getting killed by various uh things
that are going on inside the building
and outside the building so as i said
this is very much it's almost kind of
like it reminds me a little bit of like
clive barker meets die hard like maybe
that's like maybe a weird thing to say
but it's just this is a very like
action-packed
survival-oriented kind of story where
everyone like i said pretty much the
whole thing takes place inside this one
office building
and
all of the tension and suspense and
everything like that comes from you know
people getting picked off never knowing
like when the darkfall energy is going
to
manifest and it's going to make people
like suck into the walls like you can't
be touching the walls or anything like
that or it will like suck you in you
can't even be touching the furniture
they have like you know they have
safeguards uh against it but it's just
kind of like you know it's really really
easy to happen
you know and then you have like people
coming back through the walls and not
knowing what the [ __ ] is going on and
being all like monstrously you know
changed and [ __ ] like that and then
there's like some [ __ ] with romer too
who's like the the guy that's like the
head of the
special investigations team who
seems to know more about it than anybody
else but still doesn't really know
because like i said this is something
that has happened before i think they
even mention at some point like some
famous like disappearances cases like
some [ __ ] that happened in the bermuda
triangle like flight 19 uh you know the
mary celeste and all those kind of
things where something just kind of
vanished into thin air and they're
making the argument that that was
actually a darkfall storm like so
so wherever this thing was in the world
um it was just like sucked into like
integrated into some other [ __ ] and it
just like vanished so that's kind of the
whole premise of it which
like i said is a really really cool
premise um so if you just if you're just
in the mood for like a roller coaster
survival type like i said it's not super
deep it's not super like the science
isn't real you know it's just kind of
like it's believable enough type of
thing where it's just kind of like and
you can just go along for the ride and
go oh yeah i suppose so and then it just
kind of like ramps up and ramps up and
ramps up i mean the characterization is
really good um you know jack cardiff is
a really uh sympathetic character you
know like the main cop and uh even jimmy
devlin who starts out as kind of like
this real like hostile petty criminal
essentially um he really like has a good
character arc in there too and then
later on another character is introduced
to is a returner but from a very
different time so that's because that's
another thing that you can kind of get
sucked in at one point and then thrown
out like a long time later so you know
so there's there there's that kind of
situation going on too so when you have
like these characters and battling
against
all of these
people that have been sucked into the
walls and have been spit back out and
now are like monsters essentially you
know it's just a great you know and
meanwhile this whole storm is raging
outside they can't leave and it's just
kind of like you know lightning keeps
striking the building and like making
floors crash in on themselves and you
know the elevator doesn't work and all
this other kind of stuff too so it's
just kind of like becomes sort of like a
race to the finish type of thing where
you know you get to the end and they're
trying to like go go up to the roof and
they're trying to like climb down the
elevator shaft and like all this other
kind of stuff so it's like really really
good tense just like an action-packed
thriller type of thing you know but with
monsters and stuff too the only
criticism um is that maybe maybe it's it
was just slightly slightly too long
because it did get a little bit
repetitive toward the end but that's
like a very very minor uh criticism i
mean on the whole uh you really were
rooting for these characters it's just
like yeah man get the [ __ ] out of there
and it's just like wish [ __ ] started
getting shittier and shittier or worse
and worse you know you really just felt
for them to be like oh man what the [ __ ]
now what you know what i mean so it's
just that kind of story um like i said
it's not super deep it's not but it's a
great great concept i just love the
mystery aspect of it of like all these
this whole building full of people
vanishing and then with just that hand
laying there that's just a great uh
that's a great starting point uh you
know and then everybody gets like
getting absorbed into the walls that's
just a fantastic fantastic idea so i
really really love the concept of this
the characterization and it's just like
a very very fast-paced action-packed uh
you know just thrill ride of a novel so
like i said at the end it does go a lot
more into like it's not gross gross like
like i said it's not
maybe not like um i'm trying to think of
like some really really gross [ __ ] that
i read like around this time period like
is it like jack ketchum or um maybe like
douglas clegg or something like that i
think i've got
i've got one of his gross ass books and
i'm going to review at some point
because i bought that around the same
time as i bought this so it's not quite
as gross as that it's almost more like a
clyde barkery and because these people
are coming back out of the walls and
have like i said like concrete sticking
out of them and [ __ ] like that so it's
it's that kind of [ __ ] uh which is
really cool i really really like that
concept a lot
so yeah um i don't know how easy it is
to get hold of nowadays i mean i'm
assuming you probably can get it i just
bought this at like probably barnes and
noble or something like that like
in 2003 2004 or somewhere around there
like i said i'm pretty sure this
original story came out in 1992
um but this version came out in 2003.
it's weird because i didn't realize
that this story was that old from 1992.
you really can't tell i mean other than
you know people not having cell phones
and you know it being much harder to
trace people's id for example uh there
was that kind of thing
where it was like you know harder to
figure out police information whereas
nowadays would be like instant where
back then you had to wait um but other
than that you really can't tell or as i
really can't tell that this was written
in 1992 it's a very it seems like a very
timeless type of story um so you know if
if you can get hold of it and you really
like that type of thing like i said if
you like bentley little or you know even
richard layman although i think like i
said i like steven laws quite a bit
better than uh richard layman although i
have some of his other books uh that i'm
gonna review as well and like i said
steven laws this is actually not the
first book of his i read i'm pretty sure
the worm was the first one
and um and fear me
were also quite good and i might have
those somewhere so i might end up
because i'm pretty sure i bought those
at some point so
unless i gave them away or something
they might still be in here i don't know
i'll have a look because i have like a
i have not only all these books here
behind me but you know and i have a [ __ ]
done there but i also have a [ __ ] ton up
in the attic and i also have a [ __ ] ton
in that there's a closet right there and
there's like whole stacks of little
paperbacks like that like up there and i
kind of forget what i have so
so maybe i'll be doing some more stephen
laws in the future but yeah uh seriously
check it out uh it's really really good
it's just like a fun action-packed
sci-fi horror type body horror type
thing but yeah it's really good so you
should read it that will do it for this
tomes of terror and i will see you guys
on the next one
bye